So.
Content.
Shall we do some topics?
Topics, content, yes.
Yes.
Hello everyone and welcome to the very 136th episode of Octothorpe,
a podcast for science fiction and science fiction fandom,
which is landing in your back garden and staggering around a bit on the 5th of June 2025.
I'm John Coxon.
I'm Alison Scott.
And I'm Liz Batty.
And the 5th of June 2025 is a very, hopefully a very auspicious day for me
because my daughter is getting married that day.
Oh, congratulations Marianne and Kirsty.
Yes, so I, if she listens to this she'll be very annoyed because it's super small.
It's a super small wedding.
So if you're listening to this early enough, listeners, you can go and gate crash the wedding.
Yeah, please don't drop the podcast until after 11 o'clock.
I'm going to schedule it for midnight.
Go, go crash the wedding, listeners.
Yeah, don't do that.
Just be properly Vince Vaughn about it.
Alison sounds a tiny bit worried.
I like it.
I don't think you can actually do that unless it's in a church,
but if it's in a church, you definitely can.
This one is not in a church.
It depends if you've got a set of lockpicks and real desire.
See, Alison's giving us more clues.
It's not in a church.
Not in a church.
It's just a building in the United Kingdom that is not a church.
I feel like that's really narrowed it down.
So off you go.
Well, all right.
I'm going to narrow it down some more.
It's not in my house.
It may not be in Alison's house either.
I don't know.
Yeah, no.
We're having one of those things in the back garden with like a marquee
and you've seen on American TV shows.
Having seen Alison's back garden, I'm going to hit the doubt button.
Press X to doubt.
Yeah, that.
For some reason, there are very few outside weddings in the UK.
Right.
Congratulations again, peeps.
And we got some letters of comment.
Would you like to start with Chris's letter of comment on croissants, Alison?
So we just have the one letter on the almond croissant episode, I believe,
but it was a very good one.
It was from Christopher J. Garcia, who writes,
everywhere else is weird, but coffee shops in Santa Cruz County are correct.
Here, an almond croissant is a croissant made of almond flour.
My brain has exploded at this point.
They're also delightful.
This is true.
Cakes made of almond flour are very good.
So like seriously great.
The exterior is perfect.
And I very much hope at some point in the future,
I will be able to come to Santa Cruz County and test this theory for myself.
I think he also says that croissons are, as laminated pastries go, easier than elephant ears.
And as croissons turn out better with less attention, elephant ears go from delightful to weaponized in less than three seconds.
Elephant ears are a shoe bun.
So yes, I think that's pretty likely.
Thank you very much, Chris.
Your letter made my mouth water.
So there we go.
We heard from Farah Mendelsohn.
Actually, we heard from Farah a little while ago, but we've just about got around to doing this notice.
Farah writes that the Carol Goldman Fund, administered by Dream Foundry, has funds to support the attendance of Palestinian fans, writers, artists, etc.
The money has been dispersed for 2025.
But in 2026, it will be directed to support Palestinian fans, writers and artists to attend Eurocon in Berlin, which is MetropolCon.
You should contact Dream Foundry for details if you are eligible, or that's the link to spread if you would like to spread the word further.
And it is in our show notes.
Thank you very much, Farah.
We'll put a link to MetropolCon in the show notes as well.
Thank you very much to Ming-Louis for writing in.
And now I know how to pronounce his surname.
And I'll put a link in the show notes so everyone else can learn too.
We heard from Raj on the subject of our live episode from Reconnect, and we didn't come to this last time.
He says that he was almost disappointed with how coherent the live episode was.
And so clearly the solution here is more beer.
Raj doesn't suggest the more beer.
I'm editorialising that on the end.
Raj just opined.
I mean, we could say that the solutions are clearly more beer or having COVID.
So I think we should try more beer first.
That's a noted biostatistician, no, bioinformatician Liz Batty with her medical knowledge.
Correlation is not causation, obviously.
We also heard from Tammy Coxon on Blue Sky.
Thank you to Tammy for writing us in and thanking us for our nuanced discussion of the whole Worldcon AI thing on the previous episode.
We got very few letters on that, which makes me believe that we were maybe...
Were we too nuanced?
Do you want more hot takes?
Let us know.
Same number of takes per totter, presumably.
Spicy takes.
Spicy.
I've only got so many takes in me.
But then we have a pre-show, because we have a pre-show where we start doing the spicy thing,
and this tells us to stop having an argument or she'll take off her headphones and go away.
There was a very specific situation where I would do that.
Which this is linked to, yeah?
Yes.
I mean, I think I said, Alison and John, if you're going to have a big Barney about AI, I'm going to take my headphones and wander off for 10 minutes.
Seems perfectly reasonable.
On Facebook, we heard from Jan Harley, who, you know, noticed that our last episode was a little bit late,
but she hadn't missed our lovely voices because they're catching up on the back catalogue and just got to the end of number 73.
I do hope the concerns about the 2023 Worldcon at that time weren't justified.
Hmm.
Spoilers.
Yeah.
I mean, I think this is time for our regular disclaimer that we do not recommend starting from the beginning,
not least because we may have been completely wrong about something and had it all come back to bite us.
If that's the case, please don't tell us.
Don't write.
No, tell us.
That'd be funny.
Okay.
Yes.
Agreed.
And we heard from Christopher J. Garcia.
This isn't Deja Vu because he also wrote in on episode 134.
And he says,
Do you know anything about the 2006 Worldcon?
It was Worldcon held in 2006.
Do you mean this is a deep cut about site selection?
I assume so.
Probably.
We should look it up.
He also says that the Arthur C. Clarke shortlist is pretty good and says I've earned a cookie.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
So I am going to be very distressed if we discover that the Arthur C. Clarke shortlist for the first time in living memory does not have at least one book that causes everyone to go,
What on earth is that doing there?
I think it does have that book, but that book might differ for different commentators.
Which is actually always the case.
So that's quite good.
Yes.
Demonstration is a juried award and has scope for a jury with a range of views.
Oh, I've, sorry, I've just gone back and looked up the 2008 Worldcon site selection.
So the one that was held in 2006 when I think I was not really paying attention to site selection.
So I did not remember that Denver won by 12 votes.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Mmm.
So I've got a follow up question, Liz.
Yeah.
Was the 2008 Worldcon in Denver?
Yes.
Oh, intriguing.
I honestly don't know if that's a trick question.
Yes.
It wasn't.
I just didn't know that.
Fair enough.
I did not go.
I hear it was good, but...
Mile High Con?
No, it was called Denvention, I think.
Denvention.
Okay.
I've heard of Denvention.
But it was very high up, is all I remember, that there were people who went and said actually
the altitude was quite more of a thing than they expected.
Who knew?
Anyway, I'll pop that on the show notes.
We also had a lock from Ali Baker-Brooks, who wrote in on Reconnect, which was the 2025
Eastcon in Belfast.
Great con.
Amazing program.
wonderful to meet so many newer con people energised by Glasgow in 2024.
So yes, I agree with all of those things.
I think she says two things.
She says the con food was very good and very difficult for food restrictions.
And number two, it was a great venue for many things, but socially there wasn't a central hangout.
And we were going to talk about Eastcon anyway, but we are going to springboard into it with this.
What do we think on those two criticisms?
Well, she's not wrong on the food.
People who ate in the hotel restaurant, I think, thought it was quite good and quite good value.
But there was an issue around cheaper food, such as you might like to pick up a baguette or a snack.
I feel like for the hours when it was open, there was a Cafe Nero very close to the hotel.
And that was quite a good source of, you know, the sort of things they sell at Cafe Nero.
But when you're kind of saying, well, Cafe Nero is a great choice for con food,
I think that's an indication that there's a problem there.
And if you had a little bit more time to spend, then for some of the time,
St. George's Market was open and had fabulous food of many sorts.
And for some of the time, there was a chip shop.
And apparently that was very good if what you wanted to eat was fish and chips,
which I personally often do, but other people might not.
But so it was pretty limited.
That was an issue.
I didn't really notice this because we had amazing breakfast in our hotel
and then we didn't eat again until going out to dinner every night.
So I understand that I'm speaking from a place of privilege here.
But I therefore didn't notice that there weren't very many cheap con food options.
I think there was a lack of like stuff you could pick up and take away.
Did eat in the hotel restaurant and I had some very nice like vegetable soup and a baguette,
which was reasonably priced.
But then you had to have half an hour free to queue up to order it and then sit down and wave at someone
and hope they'd remembered where you were sitting to get it.
There wasn't sort of a, oh, I'll go and pick up like a sizable baguette option,
apart from a very few that were in the convention center.
I mean, I thought having St. George's Market was amazing.
The food there was so good and tasty and pretty cheap.
And, you know, you didn't need that long to go and go and snag some.
But there are people who can't get out of the hotel and convention center at convenient times.
And St. George's Market is not open on a Sunday or bank holidays.
So, yeah.
I went to the Nero a few times and I very rarely saw anyone from the con in it.
So maybe we needed a big sign saying there is a Nero over here if you need a panini.
Yeah, I mean, obviously a cafe Nero panini was a much better option than not being able to get a sandwich in the hotel.
But again, it's only open in the daytime and convention workers in particular tend to need food at quite a variety of times of day.
So, yes, Belfast was great for food generally, but the con food was not always the best.
I want to say I think these are reasonable comments.
I am curious as to the extent to which this is worse or better than other Eastcom venues that we've been at previously.
I think it's tricky, right?
Because Belfast in some ways was much better from a food perspective because it was in Belfast.
And especially like if you're at the NEC, your options to go and find other food might be more limited than it is in a city that's a capital city.
And so, yes, I don't know.
I think that's got to be part of the consideration because like the NEC food venues get very busy in the evenings, much more than the Belfast ones were doing.
As far as I could tell anyway, from my experience of waiting in both places.
And so it's probably true that the at venue stuff was not very good.
But the fact that you have it in a capital city, I think, changes the conversation a little bit, I would say.
I did think that being five minutes walk from the centre of a capital city was pretty good generally.
And that's actually something that is a benefit for Easter cons.
It would be nice if we could hold more of them in cities.
I know it's difficult.
Yeah, I think it's a trade off.
I mean, I think we've certainly had better and worse cons food wise.
I did like the last NEC one where they got the food trucks.
The food trucks were good.
The food trucks make a big difference too.
I don't think it was logistically possible to park one is a problem.
But I think a lot of the complaints on this one would have been solved by one food truck doing like flatbreads with hummus in and kebabs, basically.
And that seems like, yeah, we are making trade offs, but there might be room to solve those.
Whereas there are some places where like if you're so far out of town that you can't go anywhere and get any decent food in the evening, then you can't really solve that as easily.
I did think that Belfast shuts down more over the Easter weekend than a lot of places we've been.
There are a lot more places that seem to close very early on Sundays or were kind of closed on the bank holiday.
It is a long time since we've been to Liverpool for an Easter con.
But one of the things about Liverpool for the Easter con was that we would spend some energy in trying to persuade local bars and restaurants to stay open.
I mean, before the weekend, we would go in and say, we are doing this.
People will want to eat.
If you are open on Good Friday and Easter Monday and Easter Sunday, then things will be better for you.
I think things have changed a bit.
People say Belfast is a lot more open over the weekend than it was 10 or 20 years ago.
And I well believe that.
Well, when we were sort of discussing in committee, one of the committee members was like, remember, everything will be shut on Sunday.
It will be a nightmare.
And then I went out and ate and drank on Sunday.
And I was like, this seems to be a very pleasant nightmare, which I'm quite enjoying, really.
And so I think you're probably right.
I think my impression and especially my impression from talking to people in Belfast is that it's changed quite a lot since Covid.
And I wonder whether the shock of everything forcibly going away for a while made the restaurants think, well, if we open on Sundays, we'd get we might be able to get some more money and that might be quite helpful.
And then other people are like, oh, going out on Sundays is quite nice, isn't it?
I believe Belfast City Council also changed some.
Possibly, possibly some rules.
They made it they definitely made it easier for people to open over the Easter weekend.
Well, that's the other thing.
Having been in Vienna a week later on a on May Day on May Day, supermarkets don't open in Austria.
And on Sundays, supermarkets don't open in Austria.
So like Belfast is very open compared to some places in Europe.
So Ali also talks about social hubs.
What were our thoughts on that?
I was quite surprised to see this because and I understand that I like bars, but I thought that the Hilton bar was placed almost exactly equidistant from both chunks of programme space.
So it was, in fact, a central location.
And you could either walk one way through to the conference centre or the other way up to the Hilton's programme spaces.
And it kind of seemed fine to me.
And I spent quite a lot of time there.
Maybe not quite as much as I like because some of the time it was a bit kind of noisy and full.
But most of the time it was great as a central space.
There was also kind of there were kind of rather impersonal lobbies for both of the for both of the sets of conference space.
But I'm not sure either of those are really great hangout spaces.
They were good places to sort of rest for a little while between items.
So I think, yeah, I agree with Alison in part.
I don't think the space was quite equidistant from the two sides of the convention because I think it probably was closer to the Hilton than the ICC.
But it was relatively marginal.
And I think in general it had quite a good central space for that.
But I will also say I'm not sure I'm I've never been a huge fan of conventions that only have one obvious social area.
I quite like having a mixture of places to hang out and catch up with people.
Yeah, I think it felt like the Hilton social space was good, but it was probably a bit far from the convention center to be the obvious social space if you wanted to hang out there.
And the convention center social spaces were a bit not.
They're a bit sort of sterile and convention centery.
There was only that really that one area outside the art show that it had sort of tables and chairs could hang out in.
Then there were some other kind of scattered sofas, which I did like.
But then downstairs at registration where there were some, you know, there were some kind of displays and stuff on.
I think Blood on the Clock Tower was played down there.
It's a shame there wasn't a bit more sort of like social space hangouty stuff that you could do down there.
I think that's obviously going to be a problem with any site that's a convention center hotel split.
But in general, I thought the ICC Hilton worked really well as a convention site.
Obviously, I suspect if stairs are a problem for you as an access thing, then having to get the lift from one to the other was probably a bit of a pain in the neck.
But I don't know if anyone listening has opinions on that.
Please do write in because I'd be interested to learn.
Well, I have some opinions on this because I use the lifts all weekend.
Oh.
Which is, I think, the first time at an Easter con I've really felt, oh, yeah, that's going to make it a lot easier for me.
And they were fine.
And that's maybe why I think it's a bit more equidistant because there was just one little lift to get down to the conference center or up.
I'm not quite sure.
There was one lift that took you one floor to get from the Hilton to the conference center.
That was normally empty.
And there was the main Hilton lifts.
There was normally a not very long queue for.
So it was fine.
But they were quite slow because as well as serving the mezzanine.
I mean, that felt like a hotel that really needed escalators up to the mezzanine, which would certainly have it, but was built now or made in America.
Yeah.
Rather than that big staircase in the lobby.
So you were reliant on the Hilton lifts.
And they were kind of if you were trying to get up to a program item at a point when there were like a lot of people going back and forth to their rooms.
It could take quite a long time.
Nowadays, hotels like that are built with escalators up to the mezzanine and then lifts that will take you to the bedroom floors because of this exact problem, especially if they've got a lot of conference space.
But if they had escalators, then you couldn't use the stairs for photo shoots.
As I did see one day.
Okay.
I mean, you know, I kind of think of both stairs and escalators have been primarily to move people around a building rather than to provide Instagram backdrops.
But what do I know?
Oh, the other thing I know, the other thing I wanted to say about the layout, which is in general, it was all fine, except there were program rooms called the boardroom.
In both the Hilton and the conference center and nothing was done to distinguish these.
So I turned up for at least one program item in the wrong one and went, oh, no.
And of course, by the time I got over to the other one, which took quite a long time, it was full.
So, boo.
Yeah.
So I thought the convention would quite well from a flow perspective.
So, yeah, it was nice to look around.
Look around?
Nice to walk around.
I also really liked that the art show and the fan tables were next to each other and there was like a place you could hang out there.
I think that felt very good.
And I think part of the problem here is that, like, it's tricky, right?
Because on this podcast, we do a lot of critiquing conventions.
And I think it's good and wise to critique conventions.
But honestly, I'm just absolutely thrilled when we get a new venue for EasterCon that looks like it works even 60% well.
Because it's not like we're drowning in great candidate sites.
So the food thing, I think, like, that's an access issue and needs to be taken seriously.
But, yeah, if the bar's in slightly the wrong place.
It's also a thing you can work on, right?
Like, if we went back to site and we said, hey, you know how you sold approximately 3,000 baguettes or something?
You know, because I think we do tend to eat on site quite a lot.
You know how you sold all these baguettes.
If you did it again, would you mind putting a vegan wall on?
You'll sell another 200.
Then that's a good starting point for negotiation.
Yeah, true.
And you can't ask them to move the bar around because that would involve, like, JCBs and stuff.
Yeah, I did wonder if where we erred in the bar is because it was a bit of a thoroughfare for getting between places and was sometimes very crowded.
Maybe we needed to keep a bit of a channel there so people could actually get through.
Because I'm sure I inadvertently stood in front of people and probably inadvertently stood in front of people in scooters who were trying to get around without going outside.
So that's another possible issue.
But yeah, generally, like, would we go back to Belfast?
Oh, God, yes, in a heartbeat.
Yeah, if it was a viable place to go, I would quite happily go back to that venue on an Easter weekend.
It was, I think, generally very good for Eastcom.
And do you think it ended up being more expensive, significantly more expensive than a mainland UK one or not so much?
You mean from the perspective of me going or from the perspective of the committee running it?
I mean, I mean, for the perspective of attendees, but it's completely, you know, the comparison doesn't work for me because I just flew to Ireland.
So I'm such an outlier, it doesn't matter.
But basically, are there people for whom this was a financial drag?
For me, it was one of the most expensive Easter cons I have been to, maybe ever.
Can I just say, can you, if you subtract the cocktails at the rattle bag from the cost of your weekend?
It is funny you should mention the cocktails at the rattle bag.
But I had five, I think, excellent meals out and a whole bunch of cocktails that, and as a normal Easter con, I probably eat out once or twice.
So that's the difference of being in a big city, you know, at upscale restaurants.
So that's what being in a capital city gets.
So I felt like I had a bit of a Belfast city break.
And also I'd spent, you know, a small fortune in a cocktail bar, which I have never previously done at an Easter con, I don't think.
So apart from that, I think it was normal price.
No, no, me neither.
The NEC doesn't seem to have any amazing bougie cocktail bars.
I'm not sure why that is.
Yeah, because it's not, you know, Belfast's a capital city and you can tell.
And neither does Heathrow, strangely.
No, so it's interesting, right?
I think probably the cost of getting to Belfast by plane was more for me in Espana than it would have been to get the train down to most places that hold Easter cons.
The cost of the hotel, I would say probably a little bit dear, but it's very difficult to tell because the insane things that have happened to hotel prices since COVID, like, is that just what it would have?
It's hard to work out.
In terms of, like, eating and drinking in Belfast, probably a little bit more expensive.
But I think the other thing is that because it was a capital city, we probably could if we'd needed to eat quite a lot cheaper than we did because you've got so many options.
And also the cocktails were delicious but not cheap.
But I certainly don't, it doesn't stick out as significantly more expensive to me, certainly.
I don't think it was cheaper, but it didn't seem extortionate compared to anywhere else.
You're in Newcastle.
I thought those cocktails were phenomenal value.
And I think quite a lot of the food that we ate was pretty good value as well.
Sure, but I could easily have spent £100 on drinks in that bar over two nights and that is rather more than my usual alcohol budget at an Easter con.
And so, although I'm not saying it was bad value, it was definitely higher outlay of money.
Yes, so the convention was expensive for me, but I think every single individual thing I purchased was good value for money.
Yeah, that's a good way of putting it.
I think that's the point.
So I just had, I just ate and drank far better than I normally do.
And also I saved all my lunches, so I didn't have to spend any money on lunches.
I think you had, it sounds like there was a much higher discretionary spend, but in terms of travel and hotels, which are the kind of non-negotiable bit, it's not actually too much different than many bits of the UK.
If I wasn't staying in the main con hotel, and that's pretty unusual for me.
So it would have been £40 a night more in the convention hotel.
Although I think we probably have got about £40 less worth of breakfast, so that seems fine.
Not quite £40.
But again, like, it's a lot easier not to be in the con hotel in Belfast than it is, for instance.
I mean, Heathrow is actually pretty easy, but like, there are some venues where it's very difficult.
Fewer than there used to be, because most of these airport and off-centre sites have got clusters of budget hotels around them now in a way that, again, they maybe didn't 20 years ago.
So, I mean, I think we're going to Glasgow in 27, and we're based in the Crowne Plaza.
The first time I went to the Crowne Plaza, there was one budget hotel within walking distance, whereas now I think there are dozens.
Fair.
Yeah, I mean, there's not quite dozens, but there's, you know, there are a sufficient number, and then if you count walking into the town centre as walking distance, which is a bit further than it was in Belfast, then they count as well.
So, that's the thing.
Like, when is the last time we went to a really, truly isolated Eastercon venue?
I don't think we have for quite a while.
Hinkley?
Yeah, we haven't been to Hinkley for like 20 years.
Yeah, before my time.
I'm going to look up the Eastercon venues and find out.
Bradford in 2013.
Yeah, all right.
Would be the last properly isolated one, I think.
Which one is that?
And even then, like, Bradford, the Cedar Court.
Yeah, no, but the Cedar Court has some fabulous curry houses within easy walking distance.
If you want to eat food that's not curry, it's a bit harder.
Yeah, but it doesn't have hotel, it doesn't have any hotels in walking distance.
Yeah.
And so they basically had to put on a bus for that to make other things viable.
I mean, I stayed in a fabulous Bradford hotel that I remember was incredibly cheap.
But, yeah, that hotel is really, truly, if you don't stay there, you are getting a bus or a taxi or walking a very long way.
But that is kind of the last one, right?
Like, Harrogate, there are a few in walking distance, including one in the car park, basically.
And we've been to Heathrow.
Telford had some.
Belfort's had them.
Birmingham has them.
Yeah.
I mean, and that changes your access and your cost conversation, right?
Because it means that you've got more options to suit what it is you need in an ideal world.
And obviously, like most conventions, I hesitate to say all conventions,
although I think the vast, vast majority will set rooms aside in the main con hotel for people with access needs.
But obviously, there is a conversation there about if those rooms cost more,
you also have to make sure you've got like a bursaries program or something to make that work,
because people may not be able to afford it otherwise.
But, you know, we do do bursary schemes and stuff.
So that is something we are doing.
Anything else on EasterCon?
If you're listening to this, then the EasterCon catch-up has closed.
I hope many of you listened to some because I totally forgot and did not.
I didn't listen to any catch-up.
So after last year, my life is going through one of its periodic busy times at the moment.
So, I don't know.
It's complicated.
It is, yeah.
So, like, I probably would have done if it wasn't for the fact that Easter was directly before one of the big conferences in my field.
So my time immediately afterwards has been extremely busy.
And that is atypical.
It's usually quite busy, but it's not usually quite as full on as it was this year.
So we can only really speak for three of us.
I would be interested to hear from anyone involved with Belfast how their catch-up went.
Yeah.
Like, did they actually get as many people logging in and watching stuff as before?
Because it seemed very quiet.
And also, the con Discord usually has kind of trickles of conversation after the con.
Although, admittedly, some of the time that is due to everyone reporting positive COVID tests.
And there was a bit less of that this year.
But it went very quiet very quickly.
And it didn't seem like there was all so much discussion of stuff people were watching.
I wonder if there is a thing where you could, you know, almost plan to have people posting in the Discord occasionally after the con saying,
Oh, I've just watched this and it was great.
And encourage that because then more people will remember that the catch-up is there.
And also, what are we doing with all these catch-ups?
Are we...
Didn't Telford save them to be...
Conversation sent them to be archived with places.
That Alison will now take as she was involved.
The Science Fiction Foundation and FanAct.org.
Both with sort of statements saying, available for researchers.
But please don't stick them on the internet.
And, yeah.
So, I think that's about as best as you could.
I do want this stuff to be systematically saved.
But it is quite hard unless you said that to your people when you started.
Which I think we did.
Yes.
I wonder if we should be...
All right.
It just occurred to me.
Should we be trying to identify a few items before the con where we would like to not only save them,
but maybe put them up publicly later on?
As a sort of taster of, if you like this program item, why don't you come to next year's Easter con?
There'll be another hundred of them.
Yeah.
So, I think you could...
I've not really thought about this.
And, like, you know, this is definitely a stretch goal for future conventions.
But there's no reason you couldn't say to people, are you happy to be streamed?
Are you happy to be on the catch-up for members only?
Are you happy to be on the internet publicly?
And separate that out as a separate thing.
And then, you know, if you do have panels where people are happy to...
Where everyone was happy to be on the internet publicly, you could consider those as tasters if you wanted to.
The only thing I worry is if you have that tick box, does it make people more reluctant to tick the other tick boxes?
Because psychology is a funny old thing.
Yeah, I think maybe you do it kind of preemptively.
You, in fact, contact all the people.
You know, you identify some likely candidates.
Or maybe you look at, like, the guest of honour interviews or something and talk to people on them and say,
actually, would you be happy to do this?
Totally optional.
No problem if you say no.
But just, it occurs to me, it's like, it's a nice thing.
And we might be able to use it to be a sort of, you know, little bit of publicity for us.
And also give people on the internet some more content, but not give away the whole thing so that people have to join and watch it.
There you go.
Idea for you for free future Easter cons, which I'm not going to do any work for.
Have fun.
Yeah, no, I feel this is all part of future Easter cons.
Take note because I'm not sure I'm ever going to run another one.
So.
Do we have anything else on Easter con?
So one of the reasons I had a very expensive Easter con was that I spent an enormous amount of money in the cocktail bar in our hotel.
And that cocktail bar, Rattlebag, has just won an award for best bar in Northern Ireland.
So you see, it's not just us who liked it.
Yeah.
It was phenomenal.
Worth going to Belfast for, I'd say, if you like cocktails.
I will.
Yeah, I would say if I ever went to Belfast again, I would be making a trip specifically there.
There were other places I'd go as well.
I'd go to Raging Ramen again because that was great.
But yeah, no, I would consider it to be a place you should visit if you go.
Since Easter, I have twice been out with people and they have called out a cocktail bar to me and said,
I used to really like that one, but now it just seems tawdry.
So, you know, it might spoil you.
Rattlebag might spoil you for Commodore Garden cocktail bars.
I had a chilli mango frozen margarita for $2.50.
So I have not been spoiled.
There is a place in Newcastle called Little Lobo and they were doing chilli margaritas and they were fucking excellent.
So, you know.
Other cocktail bars are available.
I've never had a martini as good as the one I had at Rattlebag though.
So like, you know, it is, it's very good.
Oh, the cacao infused boulevardier that wasn't on the menu because we got to the point where we drunk all the cocktails on the menu.
So they had to suggest other things to us.
Yes, we did that when we went with Tammy Cox and we did the words.
I think we mentioned that in the live episode.
Something we did mention in the live episode because it hadn't happened yet is that Tommy and James commissioned some lovely sort of spirits glasses with the Reconnect logo etched into the sides for the committee.
And I christened mine with Pusheen and ginger ale, which was very lovely.
Thank you very much to Tommy and James for that gift.
And it goes in the dishwasher because it's etched.
So just fantastic choices all round.
And I don't know if we talked about this on the live episode, but I wanted to talk about games.
When do you not want to talk about games?
Games at the EasterCon or games generally?
Games at the EasterCon.
So I, this EasterCon is the first EasterCon I remember having role-playing games and social deduction games on the program as actual programmed items.
And I thought that was wonderful.
I think it went, I think it worked really well.
I think, I thought the games room was pretty good.
It was run for them by a local game shop with volunteers.
Yes, I think this is a very good wheeze.
And I think that is a good wheeze, but I think kind of my family walked in and they immediately suggested a stupid party game for us to play,
which probably wouldn't be a likely choice for any family at the EasterCon, but certainly wasn't really a very good choice for us.
And then we found a kind of headbanging numbery game.
And so I did, I did play a stupid party game the other day that I liked.
But, but no, so I thought it was a really good idea.
And I think that probably is a good model that works quite well.
If you can get a game shop that is attached to a games club who will all come in and volunteer in return for their badges and wouldn't otherwise be at the con.
Like a good bet to me.
It ran on weekend.
It was pretty good.
They had quite a lot of games, including, you know, I mean, I like games rooms generally.
So, you know, I thought this one was fine.
I think having a games club run the games room was very good because I think it divorced the games room from the culture of games rooms at Eastercons.
And I think that was good because as someone who very much likes games, but finds the games room at Eastercon has been sometimes extremely insular and not very welcoming.
I think having a company come in that didn't have that baggage, but did love games, who was like just happy to run games and be gamers.
That was very nice.
Yeah, I thought the games room worked very well.
And it was interesting to me in the light of like the Zucon run we did at Glasgow, where that's one of the scenarios.
Like I actually thought having the dealer in the dealer's room who was selling games be the same people that were running the games room was nice.
Because obviously that means that if you play games in the game room, they might be able to sell it to you in the dealer's room.
And yeah, there's there's some interesting.
I thought being able to sell them to you straight there in the game room was a perfectly good idea.
It also works.
Yeah.
Because Glasgow did this West End Games, which is based in Glasgow, ran a bunch of the gaming at the Glasgow Worldcon.
And I would quite like to see Eastercons pursue this more vigorously, because I think it might be an absolutely fantastic idea.
But I also think it might mean that you introduce the gaming communities in various cities to Eastercon.
And then they might tell people about Eastercon.
So I think it might also be advertising listeners.
It has an issue, which is that we have a bunch of other areas of the convention where it would be possible to give people privileged access to sell to our members in return for them doing something for the con.
And we tend to not do that because we've had bad experiences, obviously, in the past, but probably a very long time ago.
So this might not matter.
When also, I think part of the thing is that to run a good games room, you need a good games library and asking a member to bring a good games library and stay in the games room all weekend is very different to asking like a local games cafe to do it.
So I think that's another element.
But this is because this is also largely how games conventions do it.
Not entirely, but you'll often see at games conventions that you'll often see at games conventions that like shops run or not shops necessarily, but cafes run the board game library.
Yeah.
I mean, I think the thing we are that specifically happened at Belfast is that it wouldn't be feasible really for the people who normally do the provide a library of games to do it because it was in Belfast.
And so that might have meant by necessity.
We have to go and talk to someone who doesn't need to bring them across the ocean.
I noticed there are also snag tights were dealing at Belfast, which is a very nice idea, but I don't think they actually had much stock.
They were sort of there in a sort of more promotional way and to talk to people and to come back next year because it wasn't really feasible for them to bring a whole load of tights in different sizes over to Belfast.
And that might also be the case, actually, that selling may not be the solution for them for East to come, but they did have a lovely time.
So, yeah.
So it's interesting.
So I would be, I mean, I have a feeling that we've done this with a games shop before, but can't remember.
But I think what it sold was presumably the games company.
Well, I hope they did well out of it because what I wonder is whether we've talked to the games shops and cafes before, but they haven't known if it would actually be a viable thing for them to do.
Because they don't know like what the arrangements are between do we guarantee them sales?
Did they just come along knowing they'd sell some games on a quiet weekend for them, etc.
Yeah, I went in the games room.
We played some games.
I think they made pretty reasonable suggestions for us.
Although I think, yeah, maybe they were occasionally pitching it at like a slightly lower level than they might have if it was a games convention.
And there were people who were happy to play reasonably serious games quite late at night.
But we played some good games.
Probably depended who you got.
I think it very much depends because like, yeah, if they had suggested stupid party games to me, I'd have been like, yes, please.
And like I play crunchy games, but I also like stupid party games.
Like it's a it's not so much.
I don't think I always want to play super complex games at conventions.
Neither do I always want to play super uncomplex games at conventions.
So like my my taste expresses multitudes.
Oh, yeah.
Like sometimes I'm totally happy to play silly games.
As long as I can cast a fireball in a game at some point.
I think it's more just making sure like maybe they get just making sure they pitch it correctly.
We played the flow board game.
Is that good?
I still haven't seen the film, but I am informed it is as tense as the film, because basically at any time you're trying to build like little walkways for your animals.
And any time a wave can come and sweep them away and you have to start all over again.
And it is timed.
Oh, that sounds very that sounds very stressful.
Yes, that sounds much more stressful than I found the film.
Have you played Magic Maze?
Have I played Magic Maze?
No.
Magic Maze is a real time timed game where you're like a group of magic users trying to get through a maze, which is set in a shopping center for some reason.
But you're not allowed to talk.
You can only use gestures and each of you can only move the characters in certain directions.
And so you've got to do it all in real time just by like staring at each other meaningfully.
And it's very stressful, but it's very good.
And I very much like it.
So maybe I would very much like Flow 2.
So it's basically the opposite of Space Team.
In that it's individuals on the ground.
No, in that it's silent rather than Space Team, which is basically the loudest game it is possible to play.
Yes.
All the stress of Space Team with none of the noise.
Yeah.
Oh, that sounds good.
It is.
It is good.
Not everyone likes it.
Some people find it extremely stressful.
I have added it to my wish list.
Oh, your wish list.
Seattle 2025 is on the horizon.
And we're going to talk a little bit about some things about that.
One of the things we're going to talk about is the consultative vote on issues pertaining to WUSPUS.
So there are two consultative votes this year.
There's a consultative vote on ratifying the amendment to abolish the Retro Hugo Awards.
And there's a consultative vote on ratifying proposed revisions of Hugo Award categories for Best Pro and Best Fan Artist.
What do we think about these?
By the way, you've missed the deadline, listeners.
It was at the end of May.
The thing opened for May and May was really busy.
So we didn't talk about it.
I'm not clear why it needed to stop at the end of May.
And maybe we could discuss that a little bit.
Because the first business meeting is on July the 4th.
Yep. So why does it need to stop by May?
If that whole thing is just to get an indication of where members are at,
it seems like you could wrap it up basically any time before that first meeting and it'd be fine.
But I don't know whether you two agree.
I think they still format agendas in extremely old-fashioned ways.
And they'd wait some weeks to do it.
Ready for printing.
But the consultative won't be in the agendas.
Okay. No, okay. That may make no sense then.
I do have a strong opinion on the division of artist one,
which is that it is possible that artists does need some revision,
but this is definitely not the way to do it.
And I thought, I think the no explanation was given by Richard Mann,
and I agree with almost every word of that.
I basically agree.
I think I can see why this was introduced.
I mean, I will note it was struck down in Chicago,
and a very similar thing was brought to Glasgow.
And I guess they're going to keep going until they get it through.
But I am not sure that this is how it needs to be changed,
if it needs to be changed, which I agree it might well need to be changed.
But I'm not convinced this is it.
Well, I mean, they're basically saying that work in fan artist cannot be sold,
which seems outrageous.
Just outrageous.
You know.
It's tricky, isn't it?
Because if we sold episodes of the podcast,
that would be disqualifying, and that's fair.
But art is a bit different for historic reasons.
No, but isn't there a one quarter of your income thing for the fan categories,
which is problematic in itself, but differently problematic.
So they're not suggesting.
But saying it cannot provide more than one quarter of your income would be a start,
which would be fine for fan artists,
because I'm sure there aren't any fan artists who are making,
you know, there's not much money in it, guys.
No, I think I agree.
I think there are probably things that might want to be tweaked,
but I'm not sure this is how you tweak them.
Liz, what do you reckon?
I mean, I don't have strong feelings about the art category,
because I don't do any art.
I do see, I think what they're trying to do is, you know,
I think they're trying to clarify things a bit,
other than like, you know, fan art is vibes or whatever,
which I do agree with.
But I don't really personally have an opinion on where you should draw the line,
because I'm not drawing the line.
Basically, I think what it knocks out of fan artists
is the sort of fan artist who will do you a, you know,
do you a headshot of your D&D character for $25 or whatever,
which arguably, yeah, if you did it by an income threshold instead,
would be in fan artist rather than pro artist.
Seems like a better fit, but I'm not sure we're nominating those.
Those people who fall into that category are not really getting nominated
for best fan artist at the moment anyway.
I'm not sure.
So yeah, I will point out that the things in the consultative vote
are things that were passed by 2024 and are being ratified by 2025.
So they've already passed one hurdle, and this is just the second hurdle.
Do you think that consultative votes should be used primarily for ratifications,
or do you think they should be used before that?
Because so far, the ones we've done have been for the best indie film, Hugo,
for these two, and I'm sure there was another one that I'm forgetting.
And that has all been ratification as far as I remember.
So do we think that's how this tool should be deployed, or what do we reckon?
I think that's the only way you can deploy it realistically, because the timeline,
like, so the deadline for submitting motions of business meetings is always a month before,
and then you would have to look at those, select some for consultative votes,
and run the consultative vote in that month, which is a pretty busy month
if you are following the normal schedule of the business meetings actually at the Worldcon.
So it seems like it's something that they can do a kind of consultation on,
and you can sort of view it as, well, the business meeting has passed this,
let us also take the temperature of this year's membership as a whole on it,
and you can do it early enough that it doesn't interfere in a very, very busy time for the Hugos.
Sorry, for the WSFUS division.
Having said that, this one, I'm not sure why this one needs to cut off in May, as we said,
because the results won't be out in time to...
And the other consultative vote is on just basically abolishing the retro Hugos.
So I say, yes, let's abolish the retro Hugos.
It's time.
I was persuaded by Fiona Moore's counter-argument on that,
which is basically, we only need to do seven more, and then it goes away anyway,
so let's just carry on.
And I was like, eh, fair.
I thought that was not a bad counter-argument,
but I was also worried that if it wasn't killed,
then people would start inventing new reasons to give out new old awards,
and it's just...
So, yeah, no, get rid of them.
So we were split. We were split.
I mean, if we don't get rid of them,
I will therefore only complain in seven more years, I guess.
The issue being that if we only have to do them seven more times,
but if one of the current cons chooses not to run the retros,
then they'll come back around in 25 years.
Yep.
And when we're doing the episode of Octop in 25 years, Liz,
it will give us something to talk about.
That's fair.
I mean, I was torn on it, and I think I actually might not have cast a vote,
because I was like, I'm not sure I care enough either way.
I would like to say that on the Seattle website,
it says that Wusfus is pronounced Wizzfizz.
What?
Yeah, so I've just noticed this.
If you go to the Wusfus page on Seattle,
it says it's known as Wusfus,
and then in brackets it says,
open quotation marks,
Wizz, spelt W-H-I-Z,
hyphen,
Fizz,
spelt as in a fizzy drink.
Closed quotation marks.
And I'm like, no, it's Wussfus,
as in Wuss,
W-U-S-S,
Fuss,
F-U-S-S.
But not Wussfuss.
Not Wussfuss.
That would be silly.
Wussfuss.
Not Wussfuss or Wizzfizz?
Yeah, does anyone pronounce it Wizzfizz?
I'm outraged.
I said something weird about American,
the lack of vowels in American English again,
where distinctions just don't happen in some dialects,
but I'm not sure this is one of them.
The problem with saying about American English
is obviously that there's quite a lot of different vowel sounds
in American English.
Absolutely.
Yeah, but there are some dialects of American English
that have fewer distinctions between vowel sounds
than you would normally expect.
What I would now like to do is ask Andy Openshaw
to record himself saying this
and send it in so I can splice it in next episode
so we can get the Geordie dialect
because I think that might be quite fun.
Sure.
What, Wussfuss?
Yeah.
W-U-S-F-I-E-I.
That's what I think it's pronounced.
Oh, I think we should just please,
everyone who listens to us,
please send,
please send a short MP3 of you saying the word Wussfuss
in the way that you pronounce it.
Yes, everyone,
every listener,
every listener write in
and then we'll put it together in a big smorgasbord.
Yes, please.
Yes.
And I've been studying Swedish
because I'm going to our Capella Con next month.
Sorry.
I had some jam.
Liz, what's your non-secreture?
And it turns out that smorgasbord means sandwich table,
which is way less exciting than my concept of what smorgasbord means.
Oh, I mean,
I think that if I showed you a big pile of gold
or a big pile of sandwiches,
one of those would excite you more than the other.
I think the only way to settle this
is for a consultative vote
on the correct pronunciation of Wussfuss.
Graham, if you're listening,
if you want to do some good versus bad polls on this podcast,
do write in.
Yeah, no, but if you want to do,
if I didn't want to volunteer, John,
to splice all the MP3s of Wussfuss together
into a lovely celebration of our linguistic diversity,
but actually it does sound very good,
especially if you're listening from somewhere far flung,
like, you know, Finland or...
Newcastle.
Jersey.
Australia.
Seattle.
The moon.
We know it's Wissfuss in Seattle.
We don't really need one of those.
Can I just say,
I'm looking at pictures of smorgasbords
on a well-known internet image search
and I can confirm that they excite me very much.
Yeah, they do.
But they're...
Om nom.
Nom nom nom.
Nom nom.
Oh yeah,
are you feeling hungry, John?
Ha ha ha ha!
Right then, listeners,
that's the Liz signal
that we need to progress quicker to picks.
So there's one other thing,
which is Erin Underwood wrote an excellent opinion...
What does op-ed stand for?
Opinion editorial?
Is an editorial not always an opinion?
Anyway, Erin Underwood wrote an article on Fast 770
about selecting program participants for world cons.
It is very excellent.
One of the things she calls for is a bit more grace and understanding.
I think one of the reasons why we didn't get a lot of outraged comments
on our last episode is that we are largely in accord that,
you know,
it's not too helpful to be very, very shouty and angry
about some of this stuff.
And so yeah,
we recommend you go read that.
I would also point out,
we should link to Jason Samford,
who dropped an investigation into Seattle.
And it turns out that his reporting indicates
that all of this was triggered by a single person
who had used ChatGPT in the process.
And that's what caused everything that stemmed from there.
So it was just one volunteer who used this tool.
And I'll link to that in the show notes as well.
Worth having a read of both of those, I think.
But we won't go into detail.
I don't have a lot to say about them.
I just think they're interesting perspectives.
I don't know if either of you.
Ah, so if it was one volunteer using the tool once,
then one of the ways this spun is that
people were in a hole and started digging.
There's definitely a point there about volunteers
and the lack thereof.
I'm not sure that big internet flame wars
increase the uptake of volunteers for WorldCons.
And so if we want to have more volunteers
to avoid using these tools,
we might want to consider how we treat those volunteers.
when we think that they've done goofed.
And obviously most of the outrage landed on the chair
and the division head,
which is probably as it should be really.
But even so, it's still not ideal.
I have no idea who the volunteer was.
No, I don't think that is known.
No, and I think that's exactly correct, really.
There's no point dropping the internet
on the head of a person who did this.
In good faith, probably.
It never occurred to them, probably.
Someone who was pushed for time
and trying to speed things up
and didn't think it would be a big issue.
And yeah, you kind of have to protect your volunteers
by saying, okay, the people higher up
who could have potentially stopped this
by being a bit more explicit in their instructions
or whatever.
I think it's fair enough
that they end up being the kind of public face of it.
Yeah, agreed.
And in Seattle's defence,
that's exactly what they did.
All right, let's do pics
so that Liz can go and eat some food.
Yes.
Yeah.
Can we have one day...
Today!
Today, I want Hulk Liz at a smorgasbord
because she's hungry.
Can we do that for art?
Does that work?
Please?
That would be great.
So, yeah, Hulk Liz at a smorgasbord.
Yeah.
That's a nice, simple prompt, right?
You and I can be sandwiches
and Liz can be eating us.
Um, no.
Too weird.
All right.
The rest of the idea was good.
I might just do a smorgasbord.
It's not often you get to see Alison speechless.
So I'm quite happy with this.
Right.
Shall we do pics?
Sorry.
I'm not sure how a smorgasbord
differs from a shark coochie board.
More pickled herrings.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe.
Convey that in art.
Oh, I'm so...
I am really looking forward
to going to the Order of Darlars in Stockholm now.
Yup.
Good.
Pics!
Who's picking first?
I haven't picked yet,
so I'm not picking first.
Right.
So I am being the least original
and most unsurprising pick
in the history of picks
in that I am picking Andor,
either the second series of Andor
or the entire thing
because I have now watched it all
and can confirm it's very good.
I mean, it's good enough
that even if you have always hated Star Wars,
and think the whole thing is drivel,
it is probably worth watching
Andor, it is that good.
It's such a good show.
Yeah, it's great TV.
It's not just great for Star Wars.
It is magnificent.
It is so good at,
as a mass market product,
writing a piece of television
about what it is like
to live in an oppressive empire,
how that affects lots of different
ordinary people
going about their everyday lives,
and in particular,
how very ordinary people get radicalised.
Andor is a prequel to the Star Wars movie,
Rogue One,
which itself is expanded
from a single line
in the opening crawl of Star Wars.
So they took the single line
that said the Rebel Alliance
had won its first battle
and acquired plans to the Death Star,
and they made a movie,
Rogue One,
all about that,
and then Andor
is a two series,
now finished,
you can watch the whole thing,
television series
that explains
how some of the characters
in Rogue One
got to where they are
at the start of that movie,
and there are other characters
as well who do not appear.
And the whole thing
is just immense
in lots of ways,
and one of the ways
it's immense
is that the implication in there
is that any other
single line of Star Wars
might be appropriate
to be developed
into an entire world,
that there is a universe
of stories out here,
and including some quite good ones.
You wouldn't necessarily know this
from watching all of the output
of the Star Wars universe
at the moment,
but it's not all being made
for me,
and or definitely is though.
It's not the very end of it,
it kind of drifts a little bit,
it's still great,
it never gets less
than absolutely great,
but there are some points
in the last few episodes
where they're clearly
inserting hooks
that are going to be part
of the story in Rogue One,
and so that makes it
as a standalone product
just a tiny bit less good.
We had,
I'd seen Rogue One once
when it was fairly new,
I don't think I saw it
in the cinema,
but I think I saw it
on television shortly after.
And I hadn't watched it again,
I deliberately didn't watch it again
until Andal was finished,
but now I have watched it
again,
and can confirm
that it does the job
of knitting it all together
very well,
and also it stands up
and now of course
I want to watch Star Wars,
the one true,
the one true Star Wars movie.
So yeah,
it's great,
go watch it,
fabulous stuff,
and buoyed up by that,
I've started,
we've started season four
of The Expanse,
so,
you know.
Everyone take a drink.
Only three more seasons to go.
And the seasons do get shorter,
so you know,
you're within,
inside the finishing line.
Oh,
are they?
Yeah,
the last series
is only six episodes.
I got to the end of season three
and I thought,
well,
they've kind of wrapped it up here
as if there may not be any more,
so,
so season four,
they have to kind of
start a whole new story off,
which is quite interesting.
Yeah,
so in the,
in the books,
the books are nine books
and basically each three books
kind of tell a loosely,
like a little arc.
I think they're,
hey,
books four to six
and by extension,
seasons,
the latter seasons of the TV show
tell a very interesting,
very,
very good
kind of
solar system politics story,
which I really enjoyed.
So yeah,
and then,
you know,
book seven got weird.
Andor's good listeners,
I recommend it too.
Who knew?
I'm behind with it
and I don't think it's quite as good
as Severance,
but that is sort of,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a hell of a comparator,
right?
Like,
it's not quite as good as what I would argue
is one of the best science fiction series
is of the 21st century.
Aren't we blessed to have
amazing shows like this on television
doing science fiction?
We really are.
That we no longer have to say,
has there been any good science fiction TV?
Well,
Holland and Edison wrote an episode
of Star Trek once.
Yep.
Liz,
do you want to go
or do you want me to go now?
I'm trying to decide
if I want to start an argument
with Alison
about televisual SF
and fantasy of the 2000s,
but I think I will save that
for another episode.
Oh yeah,
no,
we could put it in as a sort of plot foot.
Yeah,
I need to,
you know,
have a bit more brain
and not be quite so...
I wasn't really thinking
of the 2000s,
you see here,
I was kind of thinking
of the 1980s.
Possibly the 1980s,
that was true,
but I think we should not overlook
the contribution of stuff
from the past 25,
30 years
because there's some good stuff there.
Although Alison will probably
get to it in about 2040,
so...
On the subject of
J. Michael Strudinsky
and Babylon 5
and good TV
from the 90s,
he's moved to the UK.
I saw,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's quite a big step
just to run Doctor Who.
I'm going to pick a book,
listeners.
Hey!
I know, right?
I am going to pick
Welcome to Forever
by Nathan Tavarez.
So this is a novel
from last year.
It is a novel
about a man called Fox
and Fox is having
a very recuperative time
and then someone makes him
a tiny little clone
of his dead ex-husband
and he very much
enjoys that.
Ex-husband because
of the death
but also ex-husband
because of
various other things.
It's interesting.
I think it's really good.
I really enjoyed it.
It's kind of cyberpunk-y.
It's about
a great many things
and it uses the
metaphor
that it employs
very deftly
to talk about
many of them.
There is a particularly
brilliant scene
where some of the characters
are walking through
a city
and then there is
a glitch
in their neural interfaces
that means the
beautiful lovely city
that they are surrounded
by kind of fades out
and is replaced
by the actuality
of what surrounds them
which is much much
less savoury.
And it kind of
comes back to that
central metaphor
and uses it to talk
about kind of things
like anxiety
and masking
but also talk about
queerness
and about what it is
to be queer
and what it is
to be out.
It talks about
protests.
the role of capitalism
and technology
in our lives
and it talks about
duties of care
and it's just very good.
I really enjoyed it.
It spoke to me
on many levels
and its ruminations
on unfettered capitalism
and on the cult
of personality
that tends to lead
those companies
and on mental health issues
all really resonated
with me.
I would very much
recommend people read it.
Yeah, it's really stuck
with me
and I really, really enjoyed it.
Right.
I haven't read that yet.
So.
Sounds really good.
Does sound good.
I liked it.
I'm going to pick a pick
which I honestly
don't need to pick
because I'm pretty sure
everyone on this podcast
or listening to this podcast
has either read it
or is going to read it
but I'm going to pick
The Incandescent
by Emily Tesh anyway.
You all know
Emily Tesh won a Hugo
for Some Desperate Glory
and The Incandescent
is the follow-up.
It is totally different
in that it is
I mean I would call it
dark academia
although the Goodreads page
is full of people
arguing about
whether this is really
dark academia
so yeah
but basically
it's about magic school.
If the magic school
was basically
a private sixth form
in the UK
and could only teach magic
because magic
is basically like Latin
it's this super niche subject
that only a few
rich schools can teach
and it might get you
into a good university
to study magic
which you're probably
not going to actually do magic
but you might go on
to another career
and it is
one reason I like it
is it's very explicitly
it's a very English
school story
but updated
to the present day
so there is a lot
of teaching observations
and lesson plans
and you know
working out sources of risk
and pastoral care
of your students
and not enough time
for everything in the day
and I really like that
I mean I'm not a teacher
but I know enough
to recognise
what seems to be
a pretty good portrayal
of teaching
in the modern system
I also
I do like the kind of
the world building
and the magic system
the Lear character
is Dr. Safi Walden
and that is explained
and it is a joke
Hey!
Yeah I spent a bit of time
going
is that really a joke?
Yeah okay
So I really enjoyed it
I found it a pretty
fast read
I found it interesting
I mostly like
the central romance
although there's kind of a
you know
a red herring
that goes on
which is a bit
too obviously
a red herring
and in fact
that would be
my main criticism
is sometimes
bits of the plot
were really obvious
and I'm not sure
if they were supposed
to be really obvious
and it's because
the narrator cannot see
like her
her blind spots
and flaws
in not spotting them
or if they're actually
supposed to be
a surprise to me
which they were not
but even kind of
figuring out
what was going to happen
I still enjoyed it
what I really liked
about it
is that
Safi is a
middle-aged woman
and I think you really
get the sense of
sort of reflecting
on her life
and reflecting
on her past relationships
you know
at one point
like she meets
her ex-girlfriend
and you can really
kind of see us
seeing like
the path not taken
and deciding like
where she gets
satisfaction from
the path she has
taken
I mean I think
you're all going
to read it anyway
but it is good
it's not quite as good
as Some Desperate Glory
but it's still very solid
I would not be surprised
to see it on lots
of award shortlists
next year
is that one of the books
is that a 2025 novel
probably yes
yeah it's just come out
I think that sounds
very good
my opinion
people probably know
but obviously
not quite as good
as Some Desperate Glory
is still incredibly
high praise right
that was such a good book
even a book
that is only 90%
or 80%
or even 70% as good
it's still going to be
entirely my jam
so I'm looking forward
to reading it
I'm also looking forward
to her appearing
at Novacom
I mean it's
partly expectations right
Some Desperate Glory
I kind of went in
with people saying
oh this is good
but not really
many pre-made expectations
whereas I went into
The Incandescent going
oh this is going to be good
it's the new Aminitesh
and so it's got a very
high bar to live up to
so when I say
not quite as good
I might be marking
it a little harshly
but it doesn't have
some of the kind of
jaw-dropping moments
I think it's deliberately
a little bit more internal
like a little bit less
like the giant
space opera ideas
it's just a different book
I'll probably get it in
hardback
and take it to Novacom
to get it signed
alright
in that case
that was the Octothorpe podcast
and it's goodbye from me
it's goodbye from me
so I have a new hobby
which really doesn't have
anything to do with the podcast
but I'm so excited about it
I want to talk about it
is it playing games
no it's buying games
and charity shops
buying games
because it turns out
that I need to go
for a walk every day
for my health
but I hate
you know stupid little
walk for my stupid
mental and physical health
and I hate going for walks
I absolutely hate it
but it turns out
that if you say to me
would you like to go
for a walk
that takes in two
or three charity shops
and you can buy games
I'm like
oh yeah no
I'm up for that
I come home with sacks full
and some of them are terrible
but some of them are great
so you know
it's good
and I was going to mention
in terms of stupid party games
we played Nacho Stack
which I paid three pounds for
in the British Heart Foundation
and it involves you stacking nachos
and then removing nachos
it is a
it is an extremely close simulation
much closer than many video games manage
video games
it's a much closer simulation
than many board games manage
and I've picked up
all sorts of interesting things
and some absolute junk
oh god
but I'm getting better
I would
that's a dangerous hobby
oh it's fab
there's so many
there's so many games
in charity shops
you have no idea
and it's good for the planet
right
because it stops
all of these games being
I don't know if it does
stop all these games
going into landfill
a lot of them end up
in landfill anyway
because I get them home
inventory them
and there's loads of bits missing
and I go
oh no that is junk
every game will
on an infinite
time scale
end up in the ground
you should burn them
if I put them in
I mean
yeah they'll get burnt
bits that can't be
recycled
will get burnt in London
ah
because we have
we have incinerators
but this is one of the things
with um
this is one of the things
a card game called
Earthborn Rangers
is it is entirely
compostable
quite a lot
more and more are
I get more and more games
that have no
no non
cardboard parts
yes
and then I get
I get games
from the 70s
that are like
giant plastic
monstrosities
yep
they have plastic
boards and plastic
pieces and plastic
balls and it's amazing
sorry that was way off
topic but I just
it will wear off
in a bit guys
shall we do the rest
of the show notes
oh also I am playing
blueprints
a lot
excellent
for those who don't
know
um
this was actually
the reason Liz
thought to pick it
was because the
art for the subsequent
episode
we already knew
in advance listeners
was going to be a
blueprint of an
almond croissant
so that was
that was uh
Liz's inspiration
for picking it
I think
is that right Liz
yeah that reminded me
that I could pick it
and ruin
Alison's life
when I was like
shall I not pick it
because it might ruin
Alison's life
oh no I'll pick it
anyway
it is good though
well it didn't
so so what happened
was that we recorded
that episode
about two minutes
before I got in the
car and went off
for a holiday
on the North Norfolk
coast
where I did not
you know I
I hardly got onto
the internet at all
I certainly didn't
play any video games
and then I got home
and John sent us
the podcast to listen
to and I got to
Liz's pick and I
went oh I have not
yet bought that game
I should see if it
will run on my Mac
and it does
and so I have played
it quite a lot
but at the moment
I'm mostly playing
games with my family
because it's my
holiday weekend
so
I'm going to say
that I have been
playing this is
massively massively
off topic now
I've been playing
the Zelda game
haven't finished it
yet it's all right
oh Echoes of Wisdom
yes
yeah I picked it
and I think Liz has
played it as well
no not yet
although I do
on a Switch so
I have I've played
up to about 90%
of it and then
stopped and this is
something I do with
a lot of games
so I'm kind of like
is this me
because you have
ADHD
no I don't think
it is I think
I kind of don't
want it's like I
did it with Horizon
Zero Drawn and
with Dredge I kind
of get to a certain
point and go oh if
I carry on much
further there won't
be any game left
so I'll just play
something else for a
bit and then come
back to it except
that I don't
it's fair
that could say
ADHD
the theme music
for this episode
was Fanfare for
Space by Kevin
MacLeod and
Competech.com used
under a Creative
Commons Attribution
4.0 license
this podcast will
end at the beep
beep
Bye.
Thank you.